looking forward to see what tj antone
has tonight the rookie drafted and
developed by the reds he was a fifth
round draft pick in 2014.
well we'll see how he fares today
against the cubs they lead things off
with ian happ
hap in the air in the corner and right
and it is
i think a home run
right at the base of the foul pole above
the fence and the cubs lead one to
nothing
that was fun
that was
a fairly unique home run
like just right at the
base
of the foul pole here just above the the
cushioning at the top of the wall so
they'll double check but that'll be a
home run and it's the first for him on
the road his first six came at wrigley
field
so the call confirmed
down goes schwarber
so it's antone against big tone
a gapper for rizzo
he makes his way towards second and he's
got a double
and with that double he's got 257
with the cubs he just passed a ramos
ramirez for 14th on the cubs career list
pretty pitch second strike out of the
inning grand tone and the reds searching
for offense from the lead-off spot it
just has been non-existent before vado
in game one earlier and here's a drive
to right field welcome back joey votto
ties this baby up at one
well he looks rejuvenated he did that in
the first game by just being very
aggressive at the plate that time he
stayed very very poised and under
control a little change up he passes
tony perez third most in reds history
288th career home run
and he chased one and strikes out again
three strikeouts for antone
the 2-2
swing and a miss
back-to-back strikeouts for antone boy
that breaking ball is really sharp here
tonight
clear skies here's the pitch swinging a
missed strike three good fastball i
think that's the best one he's cut loose
tonight strikeout for mills
casalli and then we go back to the top
of the order vato and castianos
kurt casalli high
drive to left field
and kiss that one goodbye
number five for casalli and the reds
have taken the lead
he's hit the ball hard this year that's
five home runs now and now winker
pay off pitch there goes the runner
winker
right field and go
jesse winker on fire again
i mean this was an absolute rocket shot
4-1 reds
whoa
all right rizzo questioning what's going
on here what was that and all the
umpires are coming in and this is going
to be standard procedure
is that after there is a ball that gets
thrown by the pitcher up near the head
of the hitter all the umpires going to
get together and have a huddle well you
can see that anton immediately checks
his hand and david ross wants a little
explanation saying hey that was way too
close to my hitter's head and now david
bell
wants an explanation he just threw out
david ross here's the first one and
that's a quick hook i think it's tommy
hottamy tommy hanavy the pitching coach
has been tossed and the manager's been
tossed so two outs man on second base in
contreras and david bodie at the plate
[Applause]
body launches it is gone it's a one-run
game
four to three now
and uh he absolutely crushed this one
second long home run on this trip
swing to the miss breaking ball and down
on strikes jason fitness and the inning
is over
right hander advert also
making his second appearance
throw down to first well i think david
bell was chirping from the dugout
because he thought that pitch was high
and tight to akiyama and maybe it's joey
votto doing the barking so with the this
is the one to rizzo you can see anton
immediately check his fingers that ball
slipped
the umpires huddled here's the pitch to
akiyama
probably slipped
and the umpires are huddling again
and now anthony rizzo having words with
david bell rizzo's like all right enough
get back to the dugout and now here come
the benches
bella has been ejected and
i think jesse winker's been ejected
this is not supposed to happen in 2020.
comes trailed by a run tying run at
second one away half batting left handed
a drive toward left it'll get in there
and the cubs are going to tie it
horner scores an unearned run it's a
double for half
and it's four to four
[Applause]
they are loaded up so a single and two
walks that'll be it as the situation
shifts to nate jones base is loaded and
nobody out in a tie game here in the
sixth
fly ball out into right center
akiyama will make the grab
two guys will tag in advance
cubs have the lead sac fly for horner
2-2 pitch
this farmer on the grass
the retire that comes but not before
they take the lead
aquino getting the chance
and into center field a base hit they're
going to wave around freddie galvez he
will score we're tied up aristides
aquino kimbrell v
garcia
here we go
ball gets away here comes castellanos to
the plate and the reds win it
whoa
red score two in the seventh to win it
six to five